fox news alert a stunning admission
today from the medical examiner in
washington
officer brian siknik who died after
responding to the events on january 6th
was not beaten to death with a fire
extinguisher he did not suffer an
allergic reaction to bear spray
he died of natural causes after
suffering two strokes
that is the opposite of what we've been
told for months by the new york times
the us attorney and countless democrats
in the house here to respond house
minority leader kevin mccarthy peter
mccarthy thank you so much for taking
the time to join me tonight
thanks for having me so i want to get
your response to the maxine waters issue
obviously but first let's start with
this
news about officer siknik what's your
reaction to this just given the way that
this story was depicted
in the media for months in terms of the
knowledge that we had about
the way that he passed well first of all
i'm thinking of brian cigna's family he
was a good man
and he served honorably his death was
tragic but
what's even more tragic is the way the
democrats tried to politicize it
takes away everything of what he served
for that's a real problem when they try
to
make so much politics out of this in the
in the process of what they're going
through brian served honorably defended
us
in every aspect and as we know from the
medical examiner now had two
strokes that caused his death it's very
sad it's very tragic but the
politicization i mean it has to be
something that just
completely you know is is out of bounds
uh you
have called a couple of other things out
of bounds uh recently which is the
comments
from representative maxine waters uh in
uh
the context of of what you've said here
you've brought up the issue of
censuring her something that has
happened before
in the house tell us a little bit about
that process and why you believe that
her comments in this case
rose to that level well i believe it
rises to that level because maxine
waters believes there's
value and violence this is the first
time she's done something like this
remember what she said for in the past
administration for people to get in
their faces
to to to challenge everyone and now what
she has said
has even put doubt into a jury you had a
judge announce that it was wrong i think
this takes action especially when she
has a pattern of this behavior
to have censure simply takes the
majority of the house
but what could happen if this was to
pass because of the democrats rules
she would lose her chairmanship of the
financial services so maybe then she
would learn once and for all
there is no value in violence
do you believe that there are three or
four democrats who might cross over and
join you in censuring her
i know there's probably 10 to 15 who
would love to vote that way
it will all come down to the pressure of
what democrats will put on them
to just try to vote to table it not even
to have the discussion
and if they hold together then they're
going to own
what not only maxine waters has been
saying but what talib and the others
about removing police officers and
others
this has gone on too far and for too
long
it's time to to say what is right and
what is wrong
and everybody knows her action was wrong
then and her action was wrong before
when she called for violence
speaker pelosi was asked about this and
and gave a response
today said saying maxine talked about
confrontation in the manner of the civil
rights movement
i myself think we should take our lead
from the george floyd family
they've handled this with great dignity
and no ambiguity or lack of
misinterpretation by the other side
no i don't think she should apologize
she said no
absolutely not in response to answering
a question from a reporter
speaker pelosi defending uh you know
these kind of radical statements is not
a new thing she's done it before with
other members of the squad
is there any line that these members
can't cross when it comes to
demonizing law enforcement or calling
for confrontational
violence uh that that speaker pelosi
will actually stand up and condemn
i don't know because speaker pelosi is
actually wrong because the judge
called out maxine waters what she said
was wrong
the intimidation that could actually go
to an appeal
based upon which way the jury comes back
that right there
shows that nancy pelosi is wrong but you
raise a very good point for
all the things that omar has said before
against
israel for the questions that have been
risen that to leave now
not only at defunding the police but
removing police officers
the questioning of whether our
constitution is wrong our founders are
wrong
based upon this new administration i
don't think that's where the american
public is
but it seems as though the democratic
party isn't where they used to be
that the socialist democrats have taken
over this leadership and nancy pelosi
has actually
helped along with it and supports it i
one quickly before i let you go you
obviously are someone in the position of
being potentially the speaker of the
house in two years
this is a situation that a lot of
republicans think will head to some
really good midterms for you all
and yet there's that complacency that
sets in with republicans it feels like
time and again
where they just kind of wait to have the
victories come to them
instead of taking strong stands against
things like lockdowns against things
like vaccine passports
what can you do with this moment to
demonstrate to the american people
that you're not just going to sit and
wait for what might be some good
midterms
well majorities are never given
majorities are earned and the one thing
you'll learn through us and
i hope you learned it through the last
election as well where they said we
would lose 15 seats
the first time since 1994 not one
incumbent lost there were 15 losses
on the democratic side you see that we
don't sit back we were the first to go
to the border
we're the first to call it a crisis and
ask for a meeting request a meeting with
the president
who has ignored it we were the
individuals who stood up and fought just
as you're going to find now for those
who
think violence there's value in it
you'll find that we move to the floor
when nancy pelosi will not
and that we will have a censure of
maxine waters
leader mccarthy thank you so much for
taking the time to join me tonight thank
you as always